Can you tell us a bit about what happens
during those three days in the car if we
will all beings what are people actually
do to get to come around to that.
Well why do you. First
of all i have to say
that the council of all beings
can consist of almost anything
that is congruent with those ideas
that i've expressed of being in harmony
with the earth that what we've found is
that it's the intention
that any time a group of people
gathers together for a few hours
or a few days to share with each other.
That ending of the illusion of separation
from the earth to share with each other
our love for the earth and our
desire to be more powerful
and more empowered in the
defense of the earth.
This miracle takes place
that we experience this
that we experience an awakening that
we experience an embodiment of this.
But having said that the
particular council of all beings
that i lead you know so different.
There are hundreds of people now that
facilitate these workshops around the world.
I just did in the last eight months
i've done like 20 in the united states
and half a dozen in russia and others
in holland and finn horn in scotland
and other places and.
Everywhere people are studying with me
and studying with each other how to do
this and everyone can do it differently.
You know but the way that i do it.
We usually start with the intention we make
our intention very clear because that's
what the whole experience
is based on then.
We may go into various processes that
help us to feel bonded with each other
and feel safe with each other
then we go into a mourning
or grieving process because
what we've found is
that unless we are prepared to
feel. All the pain of the earth.
We can't really be empowered in the healing
of the earth as long as we deny the
feeling quality of what's going on and
so long as we deny the pain and horror
and the despair and the rage at what's
going on which all of us feel deep down
but most of us repress then we're
kind of numb to what's going on.
So we invite ourselves to feel those
things and. From there we go.
Perhaps to an evil lucian airy remembering
where we re-enact the evolutionary drama
from the big bang matter and
space and time being created
and the creation of galaxies and then
our own galaxy the milky way and within
that the sun and its planets and
then on the earth the earth cooling
and the crust forming
and the development the
first cell evolution of
that cell through the oceans you know like
90 per cent of organic life was in the
oceans and in the last 10
per cent of the time we.
And phoebe ins came to the earth became
reptiles and then some of those reptiles.
Their scales turned to feathers
and they became the birds
and other reptiles their scales turned
fur and they became the mantles and
that was our line and we
just trace back our story.
But now it's not just written
history that we're identifying with
but our whole story the story that's in our
d in a that's in every cell it's in our
blood and we try and embody that as
much as we can and and experience
that not just as being another
story that we learn at school
but that's my story
that's my creation myth.
I wasn't created by an old man
with a white beard 4000 years ago.
You know i've been here before thousand
million years evolving on this earth do you
know and just to leave that out and
then finally we find an ally in nature
and non human being that
wishes to speak through our.
Yes in the council of all beings
it may be an animal or a plant
or some you know it may be the
rain or the sky some natural.
Anything but a human being
anything on the earth
but human we know all about
what humans have got to say
but all of these are these are the
voiceless ones they're the ones that.
Our culture doesn't hear anymore
in fact we don't even believe
that they have any voice we think
that they're just like machines
and so you know we treat
animals like machines
and plants like machines
they have no soul.
They have no feelings and the fact
that they've been evolving alongside of
us for 4000 million years is ignored.
So we find an ally and then we
make a mask to represent that ally
and then finally we gather in the
council of all beings with our masks on
and we just invite our personality to
get out of the way for a little while
and we spontaneously invite
this being to speak through us
and no matter how cynical or
sceptical we might be to start with
and of course most people
from the modern world.
You know i'd be very very surprised if
anyone came to the council of all beings for
the first time without being highly sceptical
about what was going to happen maybe
this is just psychodrama maybe this is
just a projection of our own personalities
but always everyone is incredibly
moved by what takes place
and it's different every time but always
we hear voices either from ourselves
or from each other that we've never
heard before with incredible wisdom
and points of view that are totally
alien to what we've ever heard before
and it makes us realize
that we can then speak for the earth because
we've heard the earth we if we've had
an authentic experience
that we really believe
that we've heard the earth speaking through
these other beings even through our own
voice then it's really easy
to go up to parliament house
and you know have someone say well look
you know my constituency represents
thousands and thousands of people
who are you to tell me what to do
and we can say this in my
constituency represent.
Hundreds of thousands and millions.
Species
and they're not even represented in your
parliament you know they're not even
represented and i speak for them.
You know and to speak with a strong
voice because you know we know
that we're speaking for these voiceless
ones these you know the rest of creation
which is being ignored.
Which is being shoved out of the way and
the thing is that once we recognize that.
In spite of the 2000 years of
judeo-christian you know belief or 4000
or whatever it is years of believing
that the world is a pyramid with
human beings on the top and
that the world just consists of human
beings and resources do you know
that it's just there for our satisfaction
in spite of that it's not true.
The world is more like a web and we
humans are one strand in that web
and if we destroy those other species
then we destroy ourselves so we all know
that to be true but we
don't know how to live
that truth we don't know
how to change our lives
and the council of all
beings is a way of bringing
that truth to life bringing it home
and changing ourselves not on the level
of ideas but on the level of values
and on the level of
lifestyle and behavior.
Ok what about the term sorry earthing
and very gendering who believe
that something else
that you've been forefront of well these
are there's a similar amount i started
going. Yeah ok so really a
thing and regenerating.
Two other workshop forms that
i've developed with many friends
that i work with on these things
and these are used efren techniques
to bring about the same effect of a
deep experience of cooperation
and communion with the planet in these
workshops we use the breath to bring us deep
into parts of ourselves
and levels of ourselves
that we usually unconscious of
these techniques are based on a.
Therapy that's called
rebirthing where the breath is.
So used to bring unconscious material from
the personal part of our unconscious you
know things connected with traumas
that we had early on in our lives
that we've forgotten
about and repressed and
when we remember them a
healing takes place.
So by adding a planetary intention
and a deep ecology perspective
and some other things these other forms
allow us to bring this other area
that we're totally unconscious
of which is our organic nature.
I mean freud found 100 years ago that
we were unconscious of our sexuality
but that's the tiniest part of it.
We're unconscious of our organic
being we're unconscious of the fact
that we've been evolving
here for thousands
and millions of years we are
unconscious of the fact that the food
that we eat means that the earth is
our body that every time we place.
You know it's like there's this
incredible cycle where the earth somehow
miraculously grows these things and
we take these things from the earth
and we place them inside our body and they
become our body and then we take a shit.
And the earth in our body goes
back into the earth again
and there is this
incredible cycle of earth.
Which is flowing through
us streaming through us
and we just started out as this
tiny cell in our mother's body
and we grew there from this earth and
we came out of our mother's body
and we grew and grew and
we are made of earth.
Now this is in controversial i don't think
but we don't experience ourselves in this
way. This isn't part of our identity.
Same with the water. There's
this incredible cycle.
Where water is lifted up
by the sun and it falls
and on its way down it lubricates
and creates all of life
including us a tiny part of
that water passes through our body
becomes our blood and all of our fluids
and then we piece it out
back into the cycle again
and the air cycle is the same so we
are the intersection of these cycles
and if we have a prefer.
Found experience of that as being
actually that is who i am.
Do you know i'm not some disembodied
spirit that somehow trapped in this body.
You know i wasn't brought
here from outer space.
I am an earthling i'm
part of this if we feel
that deeply then it changes the way
that we behave it changes the way
that we think so.
Re earthing and regenerating a ways
of bringing about those changes so
that we spontaneously through the breath
have an experience the changes our
identity. Do you feel like you're
developed to help develop a new religion
or just help people rediscover old ones.
Well it's it's very it's certainly
it's certainly an old one
but in this case i think that it's not
just thrown i don't get is that again.
Yep yep.
I think that there is a new
religion that's being born here
but it's not just religion.
It's it's it's very much in harmony with
all of the findings of science at this
time. Do you know and
that it's also not very new because
this is rediscovering things
that our ancestors knew about
and in particular it's rediscovering
a lot of the things that were.
That were deliberately and violently
repressed in our society by.
Thousands of years of
judeo-christian conditioning
and most recently perhaps
by the inquisitions.
When nine million european women were burned
at the stake for their love of nature
and for their belief that
the earth was alive and
that the world didn't belong
to men and to the spirit but
that the earth belonged to you know all
people into the body and to itself.
You know and so the ritual
and ceremonial life
that allows us to experience ourselves
as part of the earth was repressed at
that time. What then.
Of people who you know who would say
that what we've just been listening to for
now you know there's a lot of old hippy
drivel.
Well you know i feel a little bit
sorry for them because i feel myself
and i don't start again. Yeah.
Well for those people
who feel that you know
that all of this is just a
load of old hippy drivel.
I feel a bit sorry for them because i
feel that there's a remarkable challenge
and a remarkable opportunity at this
time for human beings to get real.
You know to get in harmony with
the earth. If we don't do it.
We're going to be destroyed
and it's an amazing thing to have been
living here on this earth for 4000 million
years to have survived the most incredible
challenges can you imagine our ancestors
the fish learning to walk on the land.
You know the incredible challenges
that we faced of our ancestors
surviving ice age after ice age
and all of them survivors all of them
finding a way through passing this precious
precious flame of life from fin.
To claw to paw and into our own hands
and then now we're going to fumble
and let it drop. You know what i
mean it's an incredible thing.
And so i feel to show people to be
so busy playing it business as usual
and holding on to those stupid ideas
that we've developed in the last
few thousand years and letting
that beautiful flame drop for what
you know for a microwave oven
and a second car and an electric
toothbrush you know such a shame.
So i just feel sorry for them and.
I myself don't believe that
the earth is going to die.
I know that you know i mean the miracle
was here before human beings came along
and it'll be here after they've gone.
The miracle was here before organic
life started there was a time
when there was no organic life on the earth
there was just stardust you might say
you know and it was itself into organic
life and into. Yes. And so that miracle.
We can't touch that.
So i'm not really ultimately i'm
not despairing because i know that
that is totally secure and totally safe
but i must say i love this organic life
i love this flesh and bones and blood
and breath and air and i
love this consciousness
and i'd be very very out of struggle
with all my might to protected
and to keep it going and you know it's.
I feel so enriched and overjoyed in
my life because of these realisations
and i see the tremendous unhappiness in
you know the faces in the lives of most
people and tremendous unhappiness
in their relationships
and their their inability to love
each other or to love themselves
that i just think people would be doing
themselves a favor to you know look at
these things seriously. Can i get a
definition of the aquarius. Vision.
Well the aquarius vision.
I just think that it's
getting back to our roots.
John said thanks very much greater than
thank you. Thank me. That was great.
Ok this ok.